The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So let's start.
I mean for the first question
you can answer what is tuple.
You can go to that later.
Can a tuple contain a list?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes, it can.
So we'll go through the
examples later.
And let's see this
first example.
We have two tuples.
The tuple B contains tuple
A, as well as a list.
So it can't populate.
Let's bring those lists, too.
So for the first example we try
to access the elements 0
and 2 of the tuple A. And
let me use minus 1 to
access which element?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
And 0 is the first element,
of course.
And remember now we
are using 0, 1.
OK, what is tuple B?
It's a two-dimensional tuple.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
It has a list and
a tuple inside.
So the first element is
a tuple, and the last
element is the list.
So now it's sort of like
two-dimensional.
But if you look at the first
element of it, the MIT word,
that doesn't have
any dimension.
Does it?
It's a string.
So you can again access,
but not this way.
But still you can access.
And we are using this notation
to access a portion of the
list, a part of the tuple,
actually, here.
It's called slicing.
So here 0 to 1 gives
you which element?
Just one element right?
It's the first element.
0 to 2 gives you 1 and 2 OK?
This is an interesting
usage of the slicing.
This is used to access
the whole tuple.
Now you might wonder
why we need them.
We could just--
the handouts are here.
So why we need to copy or why
we need to access the list
through the column operator
like this?
We'll look at that later.
It's very essential when
we have lists.
For the timing it's OK when
tuples are immutable.
So it doesn't have
a special usage.
But later on we'll
be using it.
Then if you look at this
part, this is the
most interesting part.
How do iterate through
a tuple?
You use a FOR loop and you call
like item in tuple, the
element in tuple.
The element is initialized with
every element when it
goes through iteration.
At every iteration it will
be instantiated with the
corresponding element
in the tuple.
But you're using the
same name anyway.
It's item.
This is equivalent to accessing
the tuple like this.
Going one-by-one in the range
and accessing their
corresponding element
in the tuple.
So this is the simpler
way to access that.
Do you have any questions
in that part?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For that part, don't,
usually if you have a
range you have to [INAUDIBLE]
name because is not--
PROFESSOR: OK, that's correct.
.
OK.
Suppose a tuple has 3 elements,
or for example in
this case tuple A, how many
elements are in the tuple A?
3 elements.
So what would be the
length of tuple A?
AUDIENCE: 3.
PROFESSOR: 3.
But what would be the range?
0, 1, 2, right?
So you have to type 0 to 3.
So that's why I put that, OK?
That is 3, OK?
PROFESSOR: You.
AUDIENCE: So you just say a
range like the tuple is, it
seems like the first one--
PROFESSOR: First the 0 if you
don't specify it the same way.
OK.
Now let's go through the list.
So if you go through the
questions, what is the
difference between a
list and a tuple?
What is the difference between
a list and a tuple?
Anyone?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Tuples
are immutable.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Lists are mutable.
And because it's mutable it
takes special functions to
access the elements,
add elements, and
modify the list itself.
How would you add an
element to a list?
Suppose you have list A. How
would you add 3 to this list?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's start our print.
OK.
That's good.
OK?
How would you remove
the element from
the top of the list?
Or the last element, how
would you remove
this 3 from the list?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This one?
Let's see.
You know how to check
the specification
of a function, right?
Sorry.
So it's not the right
function, right?
Because it says it removes
the first occurrence of a
particular value you are parsing
to that function.
OK, there's another function.
It's called list.pop.
That removes the last inserted
value, so it
pops from the top.
So remove can be used to remove
a particular element.
So here suppose we
want to remove 1.
So we could say list
A, remove 1.
OK.
So in this example,
actually, I have
commented out this line.
This will be an error
if I execute.
Why?
Why will it give you an error?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It doesn't exit.
Great.
So the problem here is we can't
access an element in the
list unless we explicitly
assign
something or create something.
But suppose we want to pass
a list of 10 elements to a
program so that it can assign
values on the fly.
And it can modify.
OK?
So how would you pass an empty
list of 10 elements?
OK.
The problem is if you're passing
something like this,
you need to know how this list
should be instantiated.
So you should know what
are the initial
values of these elements.
Suppose you want to create
a list of ten 0's.
Then the easiest way to
create the list is--
So you would create a list
with ten elements.
But If you don't want to waste
memory, or if you don't want
to keep anything particular,
you could do
something like this.
Now this will create a
list of empty list.
And there'll be ten
such empty lists.
OK?
And you could pass this list to
a program so that it will
assign the elements.
OK?
You can iterate to the
list the same way.
But lists are interesting.
Why?
They are mutable.
So they can be actually used
to create interesting
mathematical objects.
For example, like matrix.
So how would you create
a matrix using lists?
Any ideas?
How would you create,
say a 2 by 2 matrix?
If you consider this example,
this creates a matrix 4 by 2.
So that would be like 4
rows and 2 columns.
But how can you go and
access the inner
element or inner matrix?
So if you suppose you want
access 2, 3, that is the third
row, then how would
you access?
How would you call M?
AUDIENCE: M3?
PROFESSOR: M3.
M3 gives you 2, 3.
Suppose you want to access
the 3 and the 2, 3.
Then we--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Why does a 3
give you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
My bad.
Yeah.
OK.
This is computer science,
not maths.
You got it right, why
it's not 3, it's 2?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I thought you were talking
about 3 and 4.
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's fine.
So I'm asking now how
would you access the
3 in the 2, 3 box?
AUDIENCE: So I need to do
another parentheses?
PROFESSOR: Not a bracket.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
That is all.
So you can access matrices
like this.
OK.
Great.
We are on time.
So this actually gives you
a summary of functions.
Associated functions.
For example the pop I
explained earlier.
Remove removes a particular
element.
Extent, that's interesting.
Can you tell me what
it does here, the
method extent on list?
What does that method take?
It takes another list.
So which means it's going to
merge the list you are passing
with the list you're calling
the method on, that is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So it's going to combine
those lists.
Let's see.
So this corresponds to this.
So two lists are combined.
So this method is actually
useful, right, because you
don't have to write yourself.
Most of things you
can easily do.
Now the question is, why tuple
didn't have these methods?
Why?
Why we didn't have these
methods for tuples?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: They're immutable.
So you can't extent, you
can't [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So even if you extent,
what would happen?
It's going to create
a new tuple.
Actually, you can do that.
But like this.
For example, you have tuple
A which is 1, 2.
And suppose you have
tuple B --
3, 4.
If you want to combine them,
how would you do it?
Tuple A plus tuple B. OK?
That concatenates.
This operator is all
loaded for tuples.
OK?
So lists are mutable so you can
do all of these things.
Let's look at a few other
examples, too.
OK.
There's an interesting
part here.
Lists are mutable.
That we understand.
But how these lists are actually
stored in the memory,
For example, suppose you
have a list lst,
sorry, 0, 1, apple.
How do you think it's stored
in the memory?
So you have 3 elements.
But these elements are actually
not stored in the
list itself.
They actually in the memory.
0, 1, apple.
But you have the pointers
to those lists.
Sorry, to those elements.
So actually you can modify these
values without changing
the list itself, because the
list actually points to this
part, the container.
So in this example you have list
A and B. But the list B
actually contains list A. OK?
Since list A is mutable you
can go and change it.
So here first you print list A
and B, but you're going to
change list A's 0th element.
After changing the element
the list A becomes first.
Its first element
changed to 88.
OK.
Fine.
What do you think the
list B would be?
OK, let's print.
It contains the 88, right,
the modified value.
Why?
Because list B actually had a
pointer to list A. Which again
had pointers to other
elements.
And we modified this
value to 88.
So you're still accessing
list B. OK?
The pointers are not changed.
That we can see here, in
the second example,
the problem of aliasing.
So we have list X. And we call
it by list Y as well.
And we are now changing
the list Y. Sorry.
We are changing the list X. But
it's going to affect list
X as well as list Y. See?
Because it's just a reference.
The actual object is this.
You can call it by two
different names.
It doesn't matter.
But the actual object is here.
That's where we need
this operator.
So if you just point, OK, for
example we had list X, if you
just assign list Y to list X,
it's not going to copy the
elements, just going to
copy the reference.
Which means list X and list Y,
both would be pointing to the
same object.
If you want to copy these
elements and put in a new one,
say, list Z, then we need to
copy one-by-one every element.
For that we can use
this operator.
It's called full slicing.
It's not going to
modify elements.
It's going to copy the whole
list of elements.
And in the same line, just
another small example that
tells you how to cast a
list into tuple, and
a tuple into list.
So you had a tuple, one for
apple [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and you cast into list.
Now the type is list.
It's a very simple operation.
Can you do that yourself?
How would you do it if you want
to write a function to
cast, how would you do that?
You go through element by
element and add it to a tuple.
And then concatentae
two tuples.
Right?
So I guess you can write
probably as a
homework, try that.
Try how to convert a list to
a tuple without explicitly
calling the casting function.
OK.
Similarly you can convert
a tuple back into list.
So it's pretty straightforward.
And suppose you're getting
an input from
the user as a tuple.
then suppose you want
to make it a list.
You don't have to write
your function.
You can just call this
casting operator.
So it'll be--
it will save some time.
OK.
Great.
Let's go to our dictionaries
now.
So we have a third data
type, dictionaries.
Oh, you didn't get
the second one?
So we have another data
type, dictionaries.
And why do we need dictionaries
in the first place?
Do we need another data type?
Can we just get away with
tuple and list?
Yes.
Because you can actually make
a dictionary out of lists.
And Professor Grimson went
through that in the lecture.
If you want, you can come and
ask in the office hours.
But first try whether you
can do it yourself.
But the problem is, actually not
just the dictionaries, but
the high-level data structures
are actually available in
Python as building data
structures or as classes.
Just because they will have
these methods on these data
structures implemented.
So it would say some
time for us.
Plus those methods are
guaranteed to be state of art.
For example, if you want to go
through all the lists, then
the search function or the
lookup function that you write
may not be that efficient,
right?
But they might use those
efficient algorithms in the
standard implementation.
So it's why you should
always look for the
standard data types.
If you can't you can
write yourself one.
But it's good to use the
available data types so that
they would have this efficient
method implemented.
OK.
So in this dictionary,
we have two elements.
One is key, one is value.
OK?
So these keys actually have
a special property.
What is that?
The keys should be an
immutable object.
So you can actually have
a tuple as a key.
You can have a string as a key,
but not a list as a key.
So you need an immutable
object for the keys.
What about the values?
They can be anything.
Values can be even
a dictionary.
It can be a list.
But the keys must be mutable.
Do these keys need
to be unique?
Yes.
No?
OK.
The problem is this.
Dictionaries have the same
type, I mean structure.
This is a key.
And this key points to a
place in the memory.
Suppose you call it key A. OK?
If you assign another value to
key A, that will actually
replace the content in
the memory, right?
So that's why keys are going
to be unique, It's by
construction, by the
construction of the dictionary
the keys are going
to be unique.
Because if you want to assign
something different, you have
to call it by a different key,
call it by a different name.
Say key B.
What about the values.
Do they need to be unique?
No, of course.
Otherwise no use of key, and no
use of dictionaries, right?
What is the order of the items
stored in the dictionary?
Can you give a guarantee
like in lists?
In lists items are stored from
zero to the left, right?
Length minus 1, actually.
What about dictionaries?
Surely can't guarantee
the order, but you
can modify the order.
OK.
So the thing is first, if you
look at this example, first we
have the staff dictionary.
And when I pin the length
it gives me 3, fine.
Then I'm doing three things.
First I change the address
by calling its key.
And dictionaries are
mutable so you can
change their values.
Then also we are adding
a new element.
Fine.
If you wanted a new element you
call it by the key that
you already assigned.
If the key already exists you
will just modify the value.
Otherwise it will create a new
key and add that value.
You can also check whether this
particular element is in
the dictionary.
But this must be the key.
Whatever you are calling
here should be the
key, not the value.
It won't search for the value.
It will search only for the
key, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
for that particular key because
you access the values
through keys.
Again here if it is not
in the list, actually
I'm adding an element--
OK.
To compare in the list, suppose
I have a list 0, 1, 2.
If I want to check whether
1 is in the
list, how would I check?
Do you have to go through
element by element?
No, there's a shortcut.
If 1 in list, right?
If I want to check whether 1 is
not in the list, if I want
to negate this, I would write
it 1 not in list.
We just ignore the words.
It's pretty much like English.
OK?
We just remove the words.
OK.
In the dictionary we do the
same thing through keys.
If key A and, OK I'll
call it, say, D1.
OK?
And you actually call or you'd
search for the key,
not the other way.
OK.
There is an interesting
part here.
If you want to modify
the order--
actually I tell you that the
order C earlier, we couldn't
guarantee the order, right?
It was not the order we typed
because it starts at
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
because we added at the
end actually, right?
So actually you can't
guarantee the order.
But we can sort it.
But how do you sort it?
We call the keys and
we sort the keys.
Because remember,
every values--
if you want to access a
particular value, you access
it through key.
Actually, if you call the
dictionary, it doesn't know
where these values are.
Just you have to go to the
key to access the value.
So if you want to do something
in the dictionary itself, you
can do that only on keys.
So if you want to sort
the dictionary,
you sort it by keys.
So you call the keys method
for the dictionary--
so it returns the list of
keys and you sort them.
This is called chaining
methods.
So I have chained the methods.
I would have like two
methods, right?
I call the keys.
This first part actually returns
to this top key.
Then you sort them.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't look like
they're in alphabetical order?
PROFESSOR: Oh, on this?
Sorry.
Let's see.
OK.
Ooops.
Now they're sorted.
OK.
What was the problem?
What was the problem there?
Why it wasn't sorted?
AUDIENCE: You have to
do it in two lines.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: You have to call up
the keys and then sort it in a
separate line?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The problem is in the logic.
Actually, when you call this
function, method, you're
actually sorting the keys
returned by this method.
You're not actually going to
sort of the dictionary itself.
You're sorting only the list
that was returned, right?
The list of keys.
Although the dictionary is
mutable, it wasn't sorted.
Do you see the problem?
So that's why when they called
keys equal to staff.keys I'm
getting a list of keys.
Then I'm sorting that list.
And I'm printing that list.
But if you want to go in a
particular order, if you want
to access the dictionary in a
particular order, what could
you do is you could do something
like keys is equal
to staff.keys.
Then you can store keys.
Then for k in keys you can go
and iterate now, right?
So you can say print
k and staff k.
OK?
So you can do this.
But actually, Python provides a
way to iterate what keys and
value pairs.
That you do by calling
both elements?
All the method items.
The items return a list
of key-value pairs.
If you call D1.items you get
a list of key-value pairs.
You see that?
And we are going to iterate
through individual elements.
So first we start with this
and then second this.
So that's a simpler way to
access every elements in the
dictionary.
Great.
OK.
Now we have an interesting
part, recursion.
What's the principle
behind recursion?
Anyone?
What's the idea of recursion?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The cause itself
is [INAUDIBLE]
base case.
And it saves a lot of money.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The idea of recursion is, if
you have a problem, try to
express the problem
in a simpler
version of the same problem.
So if you want to find factorial
n, try to express it
in terms of factorial
n minus 1.
So you could keep on doing
this till you come to
factorial 1 for which you know
the explicit answer.
Right?
So you try to express the
problem in its simpler form.
It would be useful
in many cases.
Actually, in your next piece
you do have the problem.
But be mindful.
What's --
what makes it possible for
you to use the recursion?
Only if you can express in terms
of the simpler version.
Otherwise you can't.
This is probably quite like the
induction you might have
studied, mathematical
induction.
I don't know whether you studied
it in high school, but
it's quite like that.
OK.
So there are two parts
in recursion.
The first one is
the base case.
So for a factorial problem we
can express the factorial, say
nth factorial, as any n in
to n minus 1 factorial.
OK?
So this would be our
recursive case.
So what is a recursive case?
Suppose we want to define a
function factorial A. OK?
So what will be our
recursive case?
AUDIENCE: A is greater than 0?
PROFESSOR: I'm asking the
recursive function.
What would be that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: n into 2.
Factorial n minus 1 right?
And you just return this.
What would be your base case?
If n is equal to 0, we know
factorial 0 is 1, right?
What is factorial of 1?
1.
OK?
But why in this program
we didn't have
that particular line.
Why we didn't have n equals 1?
Why we didn't have that?
AUDIENCE: Because it
always goes to 0?
PROFESSOR: It always
goes 0, right?
Because you can express 1 in
terms of 0 as well, right?
So you don't need to actually
write this explicitly.
Why?
Because your recursive function
only depends on its
previous value.
So you need only one value in
advance Which means you need
only one value for
your base case.
So you can understand
this program, right?
I'm not going to go
through that.
But anyway when you write
a program always
check its base case.
So you have to start with
factorial 0 for this case.
OK?
And check one by one.
Then you would know whether
the program is running
correctly or not.
So always start with
a simpler case.
But remember in Fibonacci
series.
OK. for Fibonacci series
can you give me
the recursive function.?
Yes.
What is Fibonacci series?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
That's great.
So return say F of n minus
1 plus F of n minus 2.
What is the Fibonacci series?
You start from 0, you
add these elements.
So 1.
You add last two elements, 2.
You add last two elements, 3.
You add last two elements, 5.
So you add last two elements.
So if you want to find F of n,
you return F of n minus 1 and
plus F of n minus 2.
But here since you have two
elements, or you need to
access two previous elements,
you need to define you base
case accordingly.
So for your base case,
F of 0, is what?
Actually, that depends
on whether you
start here or here.
OK?
You could do this.
I'll go through an interesting
recursive example.
OK.
It's called a recursive
exponentiation.
So I actually you can do an
exponentiation through
recursive multiplication.
Suppose you want to find 3
to the power, say, of 10.
Then how would you do that?
You start by expressing
it in terms of its
simpler version, right?
So it will be 3 into
3 to the power 9.
Sorry, 3 to the power 9.
OK?
So if you want to find that
nth power of number M, you
would say M into M to
the power n minus 1.
So now you have your
recursive case.
What is the base case?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, if
n is equal to 0.
In Python you would test this
by two equal signs.
If n is equal to 0, then what?
AUDIENCE: Return 1.
PROFESSOR: Return 1.
OK?
Why we have only one
base case here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And because you're accessing
only one
previous series, right?
Fibonacci series.
Similarly, if you want to
multiply something--
OK, here what we did is we
replaced this operator by
recursively using
this operator.
OK?
Can you do the multiplication
by recursive addition?
So can you replace this operator
by this operator?
Yes.
So how would you do this, for
example say 3 into 5?
So how would you do it here?
Tell me.
What would this?
AUDIENCE: 3 plus 3 times 4.
PROFESSOR: 3 plus?
AUDIENCE: 3 times 4.
PROFESSOR: 3 times 4.
Here?
Come on, it's simple, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm insulting you.
OK.
What's the base case?
That is interesting.
What is the base case
if n is equal to 0?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
If n is equal to 0, that is 0.
But that's fine.
But there's another problem.
The problem is you don't know
whether these values are
positive or negative.
So you can't just keep
on adding like this.
This will work if
it's positive.
But if it's negative, actually
you have to check.
Which is sort of tricky
if you want to use the
same recursive function.
Otherwise you could have
an if condition here.
If say n is greater
than 0, do this.
Else-if you multiply n by minus
1 you negate that so it
becomes positive.
And do it the same way and
then that's the answer.
So you could do that.
But if you want to do it in the
same recursive case, then
you had to follow this.
If you have any questions,
come to the
office hours on that.
The final question is, final
example is, the Hanoi example.
OK.
This is very interesting.
So here we have three towers;
source, target, and buffer.
Suppose you have three disks.
You want to move them from
source to target.
And you can always have a
smaller disk on top of a
bigger disk.
Then how would you move?
OK?
So can you express this problem
in a simpler version?
So now we have three disks.
You want to move
them to target.
So can you express it in
a simpler version?
Come on.
Just in plain English,
how would you do it?
Without looking at
the program.
Because Python is very robust.
So if you read the program
you get it in English.
So any ideas?
OK.
We have to here move the last
disk to target, right?
But that's the hardest part.
So before doing that you have
to move this somewhere else.
So let's move it to buffer.
Done.
How would you move this?
Now you can move it to target.
OK.
Now what would you do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Sorry.
Yeah, OK?
No.
What would you do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You can only move
this to the buffer, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[?
PROFESSOR: Not the target.
OK.
So we made some mistake
earlier.
Remember?
The problem is because we didn't
think recursively.
OK.
Let's think recursively.
Source, target, buffer.
Sorry.
Suppose we have only one disk.
Then you can simply
move to target.
OK?
So a condition is if there's
only one disk, just move it to
the target.
So if n is equal to 1
we always move from
move source to target.
OK?
Suppose you have two.
Then what would you do?
You move the top
one to buffer.
OK?
So move source to buffer.
Then you move the next disk
from source to target.
So now it's source to target.
And finally you move
it from the buffer.
All right?
Now we have a very nice
recursive case.
If you have two, we move from
source to buffer, then source
to target, then from
buffer to target.
So if you look at this example
I'm checking if
n is equal to 1.
If it is 1, just I'm moving
from source to target.
If it is greater than
n, what would I do?
And that first assert statement
is just there to
make sure that n is
greater than 0.
Otherwise it's meaningless,
right?
You need to have this.
You can't have negative this.
So what would be the next
step if you have
more than one disk?
Suppose you have two disks.
Then what would you do?
You move the top disk
or whatever on
the top to the buffer.
For this simple example
it was just one disk.
But suppose you had more disks
on top of the last disk?
So you would have moved
all of them to buffer.
You don't have to worry
how you move it.
But you have to move
it anyway.
After moving that, you can
leisurely move this big disk
to the top, to the target.
OK?
Finally, you bring back all
of them here, right?
For you first operation, for
your first operation, from
source to target, you have
to move all of them, the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
You could have used target
as your buffer.
OK?
So that's why in this line I'm
using source as source.
But the second argument, which
should have been the target,
is now buffer because my current
target is buffer for
the top n minus 1 disk.
But my buffer is
now the target.
OK.
Because I can use the target
as buffer for the movement.
Then I moved from source to the
target, the last big disk.
OK?
For that I can use buffer
as my buffer.
Then finally I bring back from
buffer to target using source
as my buffer.
OK?
So the thing is if you want to
have a recursive problem you
can do it in two ways.
One thing, you can start
thinking how to express this
problem in its simpler version
like how you thought about the
Fibonacci series,
for instance.
Or else, you can start from
its base case, the most
fundamental situation.
So here it's n equal to
1, but this doesn't
give you enough context.
So you go to the next level, n
is equal to 2, and you have
the answer.
Right?